et
danger pour correa quinio la présidente
des philippines triomphe de justesse
d'une révolte militaire
le réalisateur américain john huston est
mort à l'âge de 82 ans il entre dans la
légende du cinéma avec plus de 40 films
dont plusieurs chefs-d'oeuvre le
contrôle des voitures d'occasion un gage
de sécurité pour les acheteurs et
parfois une bonne affaire pour les
garagistes une journée supplémentaire de
détention pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir
la présidente de tous les dangers coria
quinio en moins de deux ans de pouvoir
aux philippines a déjà connu cinq
tentatives de coups d'état dont la plus
sérieuse a débuté la nuit dernière près
de 15 cents militaires ont occupé des
bâtiments publics de la capitale une
télévision le quartier général de
l'armée
la situation est restée confuse pendant
plusieurs heures mais finalement les
troupes demeurer loyal à manama qui nous
ont obtenu la reddition des mutins au
terme de combats qui ont fait au dernier
bilan
cinquante cinq victimes jérôme bellay
combats de rues toute la journée à
manille où après avoir attaqué le palais
présidentiel cette nuit des soldats
rebelles se rende maître ce matin du
quartier général de l'armée et de deux
chaînes de télévision au milieu de
civils que l'habitude des putschs semble
rendre indifférent aux risques les
fusilliers marins fidèles au
gouvernement essaie de reprendre
l'immeuble de la quatrième chaîne
à l'intérieur un groupe d'insurgés
diffuse un message leur objectif mater
la guérilla communiste qui est selon
leurs propres termes
aux portes de la ville et que leurs
généraux sont incapables de vaincre à la
mi journée
l'immeuble est repris et un groupe de
rebelles arrêtés
cet après midi la présidente cory aquino
dont le fils a été blessé à la jambe
lens publiquement l'ordre d'écraser la
rébellion et de donner l'assaut au qg de
l'armée où est retranché le groupe le
plus important environ 15 cents hommes
devant la foule
la gare spectacle continue elle a déjà
fait 55 morts et une centaine de blessés
à la tête des troupes loyales au
gouvernement le général ramos chef
d'état major des armées
après avoir ordonné le bombardement de
la caserne
il assure qu'il a la situation bien en
main les rebelles commencent à se rendre
mais d'autres groupes contrôlent
toujours l'aéroport de manille et
plusieurs casernes du reste de l'île
cette révolte militaire est la plus
dangereuse donc et eut essuyé la
présidente des philippines dont le
pouvoir apparaît bien fragile dans un
pays où l'alternative se résume toujours
à des tentatives de gouvernement
démocratique où des dictatures
militaires
le tout sous la surveillance vigilante
des états unis pour qui il faut le
savoir les philippines restent une
chasse gardée en raison de sa position
stratégique
daniel 2 février 86 un dictateur sur le
déclin et déposer une petite dame en
jaune le remplace cory aquino succède à
ferdinand marcos
c'est l'armée qui a fait marcos c'est
avec l'armée et par l qu'il a gouverné
le pays pendant 20 ans mais c'est
l'armée qui va le défaire sans larmes et
rien n'est possible coriat qui nous est
donc sous influence dès le premier jour
deux hommes incarnent cette continuité
le premier juan pons seine rive est un
pilier du régime précédent
il est nommé ministre de la défense le
deuxième
fidel ramos un autre en force marcos il
devient lui avec cory aquino chef d'état
major de l'armée
passées les premières semaines ces deux
hommes vont peu à peu devenir les
avocats d'une armée mal dans sa peau
une armée qui acceptent de moins en
moins l'ouverture par le gouvernement de
négociation avec la guérilla communiste
quel combat tous les jours sur le
terrain d'une arme et surtout qui refuse
d'être dépossédé de ce pouvoir politique
dont elle a usé à sa guise pendant si
longtemps résultat trois tentatives de
coups d'état en moins d'un an et à
chaque fois l'impunité pour les
putschistes qui comme ici regagne pour
la plupart leur quartier sans être
sanctionné seul juan pons et ennery les
soupçonnaient de préparer un coup d'état
est contraint de démissionner en octobre
86 il devient leurs sénateurs et chef de
file de l'extrême droite militaire
hier certains insurgés se sont réclamés
de son soutien les militaires philippins
en donc pas désarmé mais ce qui a fait
leur force le soutien des états unis au
moment du renversement de marcos fait en
même temps leurs faiblesses
dell annonce du dernier coup d'état les
etats unis ont dénoncé la nouvelle
tentative
et sans le soutien de washington rien
aux philippines n'est possible les
forces armées libyennes ont elles oui ou
non attaqué et repris la localité
frontalière daoudou au tchad
tripoli affirme que oui djamena répond
que non et dans les milieux militaires à
paris ont fait état d'une offensive sans
plus de détails c'est tout ce que l'on
peut dire ce soir
faute d'autres informations et surtout
d'image john huston le metteur en scène
américain vient de mourir à l'âge de 82
ans
avec son visage à la hemingway il
faisait partie de ces quelques grands
réalisateurs dont le nom apparaît
souvent en plus gros que celui des
acteurs sur les affiches de ses fils au
cours d'une carrière mouvementée il
avait réalisé plus de 40 films dont le
trésor de la sierra madre et le faucon
maltais monique atlan à rhode island le
géant s'est endormi dans son sommeil
john huston c'est tout laventure du
cinéma incarné en un seul homme quarante
films 46 ans de carrière
à genoux stone a touché à tout et nous a
conquis à chaque fois fils d'acteurs
d'origine irlandaise houston puis tour à
tour champion de boxe et de 7 ans
peintre cavaliers dans l'armée
révolutionnaire de pancho villa au
mexique avant de s'orienter vers le
cinéma scénariste à la warner il signe
son premier film 41
le faucon maltais qui immortalise le
polar comme genre cinématographique on
retrouve bogard pour le trésor de la
sierra madre qui lui vaut trois oscars
il lui confère une audience
internationale
dès ce moment la liste de ses succès sa
loge qu'elle a rouen 48 africaine
fouesnant 51 les désaxés dans lequel il
dirige pour la dernière fois
klare gameboy marilyn monroe et
montgomery clift la nuit de l'iguane
avec havas garnett toutes les stars
d'hollywood sont passés devant sa caméra
ici james mason paul newman dominique
sanda dans macintosh mène en 1972 où
jack nicholson dans l'honneur des prizzi
dans les années 80 houston adapte le
roman de malcolm lowry au dessous du
volcan avec albert finney et jacqueline
bisset dans les rôles principaux
je nous a réunis tous une semaine avant
le tournage l'acteur américain et
mexicain
nous avons lu nos rôles si j'y vais il
est très intéressant parce qu'il écoute
avec les oreilles plus qu'avec les yeux
les on écoute généralement ecclésiaux la
sq lui sont fermes les yeux souvent et
longtemps tous les deux temps en temps
changer un mot un seul mot du script sur
lequel il a travaillé un mois avec le
graphisme de plus en plus ment il rend
le tout plus linéaire il élimine tout le
superflu
dernier défi que lance john huston au
cinéma la mise en scène d'une nouvelle
de james joyce les gens de dublin
un film qu'il souhaitait aventure
familiale avec ses enfants angelica et
tony titre original du film qui sera
présenté à venise la semaine prochaine
the dead ou la mort jean-philippe john
huston n'a pas franchement tourné deux
films comiques et pourtant vous dites à
propos de sa personnalité
c'est surtout un homme drôle qui a
beaucoup d'humour il ya le mot est
toujours là tant le son dernier film
l'honneur des prizzi gh
il ya un reer dessous en permanence et
s'éteint c'est à dire que j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer un jour et il était
il était malade il avait popularisé dans
les années 60 et il n'arrêtait pas de
rire peinture cette interview c'est
passé dans de grands éclats de rire au
bout du compte j'ai interrogé sur le
rire et emma il m'a raconté une histoire
que fat fabuleuse qui était celle de son
père walter huston qui était un immense
acteur du pto broadway 2t a troué et
dont le rêve était de jouer othello bon
hilton se fait du souci pour son père
la représentation a lieu hilton adore
pas de la nuit lit les premiers journaux
du matin
les critiques sont excécrables alors il
va à l'acte dans la chambre d'hôtel de
son père se disant mais il doit être
ils devraient être perdus avec des
crédits pas et dans le couloir il entend
un immense rire un rire le so lu ment
énorme qui était celui de walter huston
en train de dire des critiques
absolument qui le révolte et c'est
complètement empruntait et crier et
houston pour lui sourire était une leçon
c'était une leçon tout au long de sa vie
hilton est quelqu'un qui a qui a ride
l'échec qui arrive l'absurde et c'est
sous jacent c'est sous jacent dans tout
cela on dit qu'il a une carrière
mouvementée c'est exact des victimes du
mccarthysme et qui viole ude etc
oui enfin qu'il a mouvementée lui aussi
pas maintenant quand ils stone part en
guerre en 1943 il apprend dans la
journée que qu'il est engagé dans la pac
il est mobilisé dans la mère américaine
il a une scène à tourner avec boga boga
décerné par des japonais est il
s'arrange pour que deux gars ne puisse
pas être libérés c'est à dire qu'il
attache à sa chaise
il cerne la maison d'une centaines de
japonais et puis téléphone pour
d'experts en disant écoutez je pars à la
guerre bogaert débrouillera comme il
pourra alors chaque fois qu'un un grand
réalisateur dix périodes il entre dans
la légende qu'est ce qui restera de son
oeuvre qui est vraiment mérite de dire
qu'ils entrent dans la légende de c2c de
son premier le faucon maltais jusqu'au
dernier en passant par la reine
africaine en passant par ta de city en
passant par des les quantités de films
on trouve quelqu'un qui est beaucoup
plus calmes et en scène c'est quelqu'un
qui a commencé par écrire et qui était
extrêmement intelligent qui donc a pu
épouser l'évolution de hollywood dans
les années 40 dans les années 50 60 70
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
2 c'est tout le contraire de quelqu'un
ces fameux metteur en scène américain
qui trouvaient leur scénario vous
préparer
la veille du tournage hilton était
quelqu'un qui écrivait ses films et qui
n'a pas cessé au fond de s'améliorer
vous allez lui consacrer une soirée
peut-être par hasard par hasard c'était
c'était prévu le faucon maltais était
prévu prévue pour la reprise du ciné
club en septembre
merci claude jean phi ils se sont enfin
rencontrés
jacques chirac et madonna la chanteuse
rock ont fait qu'on ait connaissance
dans les salons de l'hôtel de ville à
paris cet après midi à l'occasion d'une
cérémonie au cours de laquelle la reine
du rock a remis un chèque de 500 mille
francs à l'association de lutte contre
le sida
présidée par line renaud jean jacques
dufour 18h madonna superstar sort de
l'hôtel crillon direction l'hôtel de
ville entourée de ses gardes du corps
elle s'engouffre dans une mercedes noire
suivie par une meute de photographes
après un bref entretien privé avec le
premier ministre la chanteuse remet
500000 prend à line renaud pour sa
fondation de lutte contre le sida
je voudrais dire que c'est un privilège
d'être ici à paris pour ce concert est
aussi et surtout que je suis très
heureuse de remettre ce chèque à line
renaud pour son action en faveur de la
lutte contre le sida
de tout coeur
je voudrais remercier madonna parce que
c'est vraiment chic c'est vraiment sympa
de sa part de faire un geste pareil
c'est très symbolique de son attachement
à la lutte contre les uns plus haut qui
touche tout le monde et notamment la
jeunesse
une demi-heure après son arrivée à
l'hôtel de ville
madonna repartez toujours sous haute
surveillance
ces dernières semaines et vous l'avez
encore remarqué tout le monde a remarqué
l'offensive du premier ministre vers les
jeunes avec en plus de son intérêt pour
la chanteuse madonna que lui a fait
découvrir sa fille une réflexion de
l'ancien ministre de la culture jack
lang qui ironise sur ce thème en parlant
des gros sabots de la récupération et
ajoutant à quand monsieur chirac avec
des bottes et des boucles d'oreilles
il y à un mois comme si de rien était
jacques anquetil commentaires en direct
sur notre chaîne le tour de france
cycliste tous les jours il y a deux
semaines il se faisait opérer d'un
cancer de l'estomac
le lendemain il se levait et la semaine
prochaine il sera présent aux
championnats du monde cycliste sur route
comme directeur technique de l'équipe de
france alors est ce simplement un
exemple de volonté ou les sportifs sont
ils mieux armé que d'autres pour relever
le défi de la maladie l'enquète de notre
spécialiste peerle c'était il ya trente
ans jacques anquetil remportait pour la
première fois le tour de france une
épreuve qu'il a gagné cinq fois aux
temps héroïques et qu'il a encore suivi
il ya un mois personne ne se doutait
alors que l'ancien champion était
confronté à une autre épreuve le cancer
voilà 17 jours qu'il a été opéré il est
déjà remonté sur un vélo
je re même fait de la bicyclette neuf
jours après l'opération j'ai peut-être
été un petit peu vite en besogne m'enfin
là je pense que c'est aléatoire alors
vous êtes l'une des rares personnes qui
soient connus et qui avouent les raisons
de cette opération en fait les raisons
re environ s'est opérée d'un ulcère de
l'estomac c'est ce que dit j surgir les
médecins la véritable raison c'est que
c'est un cancer de l'estomac sinon ben
on n'aurait pas fait une gastrectomie
c'est puis si j'avais su que ce soit car
il sait que je me sens jamais fauté et
heureusement qu'on m'a dit la vérité
j'avais demandé à l'endoscopie au
médecin qui vous attend de skopies comme
dit la vérité quand j'ai su que c'était
ça et bien le diagnostic a été formel
bieber ma ligne j'ai pas d'erreur on
sait que c'est un cancer de l'estomac il
fallait enlever tous les sba
récupération étonnante pourtant qu'un
ancien champion ce remède si vite et si
bien ça n'étonne pas le spécialiste il
récupère vite les sportifs en règle
générale cependant c'est vrai trois pour
deux raisons parce que ils ont une
meilleure constitution musculaire
physique et que c'est un très bon
élément de récupération et d'autre part
psychologiquement ce sont des sujets qui
ont eu à faire face à des épreuves
or la chirurgie est une épreuve et ils
sont très près à se battre contre la
maladie
un champion il veut se battre et de se
battre contre l'adversaire il ya plus
d'un adversaire si ce n'est la maladie
se battent contre lui contre son
organisme qui est défaillant et je crois
que ça donne un stimulus fantastique
les recherches se poursuivent pour
retrouver le terroriste basque français
philippe bidart signaler cette fois ci
dans les pyrénées atlantiques où on a
retrouvé une nouvelle voiture volée par
lui et sa compagne
le gendarme qu'il est accusé d'avoir tué
a été enterré cet après midi à
biscarrosse en présence du ministre
défense monsieur giraud le gendarme
roger bushman 37 ans a été cité à
l'ordre de la nation dans l' enquête sur
le meurtre d'un autre gendarme encore
cette fois-ci le 4 août dernier un homme
qui n'est encore qu'un témoin gérard
peslier interrogé depuis plus de trois
jours maintenant a été transféré à paris
où il pourrait bien être inculpé
dominique fait l'imprudence qu'elle fait
tomber gérard peut lier petit truand
spécialiste des chèques volés
il sera sans doute demain inculpé de
complicité d'assassinât dans l'attentât
contre la patrouille de gendarmes de
bastia pour quelques milliers de francs
il avait accepté de loger dans sa
chambre d'hôtel deux hommes armés
d'effectuer quelques repérages sans
savoir dit il que l'opération de se
préparer
une heure après la fusillade du 4 août
qu'il apprend par la radio la mort d'un
gendarme trois autres sont blessées il
s'enfuit précipitamment sans payer sa
note d'hôtel ténacité des enquêteurs
l'attentât à l'époque avait été
revendiqué par l'ex référénce et peu de
témoins avaient assisté à la fusillade
les policiers tenaient une piste ils ne
l'ont pas lâché
si l'on ne sait pas encore qui a
mitraillé la fourgonnette des gendarmes
peu lié à révéler les noms des
indépendantistes qui l'avait contacté
lors d'un séjour à la prison d'ajaccio
peu lié à donner le signalement des deux
hommes armés qui l'a hébergé la veille
de l'attentât
il y a quatre jours maintenant que huit
prisonniers détiennent en otage
plusieurs membres du personnel de la
prison italienne de lindell rien
n'indique que ce soir que le dénouement
soit proche au contraire même le
terroriste ni aux fascistes mario tout
petits qui est à la tête des mutins
s'est fait livrer une grande quantité de
vivres
il a également demandé l'installation
d'une ligne téléphonique directe
rappelons que les preneurs d'otages
réclame d'un hélicoptère pour quitter
l'enceinte de l'établissement
pénitentiaire
l'éventuelle candidature de monsieur
mitterrand un second mandat présidentiel
au centre des sujets de discussion des
discours des universités d'été du parti
socialiste et du rpr chez les gaullistes
on ironise sur ce thème
exemple le discours du ministre des
affaires sociales philippe seguin et
l'attaquant règles continue après franck
borotra hier soir et avant charles
pasqua demain c'était aujourd'hui
philippe séguin qui s'en prenaient au
président de la république toujours
devant les jeunes du rpr est toujours en
ironisant sur les divisions des
socialistes alors résumons nous parce
que on s'y perd si monsieur mitterrand y
va et si monsieur rocard n'y va pas
bonjour la dérision
si monsieur mitterrand y va et si
monsieur roch arriva bonjour la division
si monsieur mitterrand n'y va pas et si
monsieur roch tu arrives à coeur des
barons et moi et moi et moi bonjour
l'anarchie on n'a pas filer on n'a pas
fini de sourire aujourd'hui avec dans la
poche quelques bons indices philippe
seguin qui l'on prête un rôle de plus en
plus important dans la prochaine
campagne présidentielle apparaît de plus
en plus comme un des hommes forts du
gouvernement
alors on ironise on se moque au rpr
c'est le jeu politique on s'inquiète en
revanche au parti socialiste devant la
floraison des candidatures au cas où le
président se retirerait monsieur lionel
jospin exprime cette inquiétude en
l'employant lui une métaphore sportive à
la veille des championnats du monde ou
en athlétisme
nous avons plusieurs athlètes
socialistes qui ont réalisé ou qui
peuvent réaliser ce qu'on appelle les
minima dans cette épreuve particulière
que l'élection présidentielle le moment
venu il n'y a qu'un athlètes
sélectionnés alors nous n'en sommes pas
encore à la sélection de notre candidat
viendra et il nous rassemblera les
minima et le parti socialiste vous savez
à une chance extraordinaire dans la
période qui vient c'est qu'ils donnent
aux seuls partis en france à savoir qu'
il sera au second tour donc il y eut
pluie peut déjà penser au troisième
nouvelle calédonie le parti communiste
la fédération du parti socialiste de la
région parisienne le syndicat cgt et la
fédération de l'éducation nationale
solidaire pour participer au
rassemblement des indépendantistes du
fln cahez qui doit avoir lieu mardi
prochain à paris
c'est une première pour l'industrie
nucléaire française qui prend pied sur
le marché américain la cogema framatome
et pechiney s'associent en effet à 50 50
avec l'américain babcock & wilcox pour
fabriquer le combustible nucléaire dans
l'avenir cette coopération pourrait
s'étendre à d'autres domaines
jean-pierre médias
c'est une première pour les français ils
viennent d'être admis dans le club très
fermé du nucléaire américain afin de
fabriquer ces barres d'uranium
le combustible des centrales nucléaires
c'est une nouvelle société qui se crée
ainsi regroupant trois français
framatome cogema et pechiney et un
américain babcock un marché de 2
milliards et demi de francs par an une
aubaine au moment où la construction des
centrales est gelée dans le monde entier
le marché américain est un marché
nucléaire est un marché très important
parce qu'il existe tradi si la fin du
siècle aux états unis à peu près le
double d'unités nucléaire de production
d'électricité qui n'en existera en
france deux fois plus de centrales et
donc deux fois plus de déchets à
retraiter
c'est l'autre spécialité française que
nous allons vendre aux usa actuellement
les américains stopper provisoirement
leurs déchets en piscine en l'an 2000 il
y en aura 40 mille tonnes qu'il faudra
bien savoir retraités comme ici à
l'usiné de la hague
hier soir nous vous parlions ici même
automobile et vitesse ce soir automobile
encore mais automobile et réparation en
effet depuis un peu plus d'un an
maintenant en cas de revente d'un
véhicule vous devez faire constater par
un garagiste agréé les éventuelles
défaillances mécaniques de votre voiture
alors il ne faut pas généraliser bien
sûr mais certains garagistes ont
tendance on tue tendance et ont tendance
à allonger un peu la facture enquête de
florence mavic et roland sig clinquante
à l'extérieur mehdi dessous qui laisse à
désirer
la voiture des français souvent des
allures trompeuse corrosion du bas de
caisse fera en mauvais état suspension
défaillantes selon les spécialistes 80%
des véhicules de plus de 5 ans devrait
être réparé actuellement 4400 centre de
contrôle technique fonctionne en
majorité des garages réparateur agréé
par la préfecture sur simple candidature
souvent les pouvoirs publics n'ont pas
eu le temps de vérifier leur matériel de
contrôle cela parfois au détriment de la
fiabilité
il suffisait
par exemple un appareil pour mesurer la
profondeur des pneumatiques
une balade aux pommes c'est pas
suffisant pour faire un contrôle
technique pourtant les agréent mais j'ai
pensé qu'ils étaient obligés de fuir
autres parce qu'autrement monsieur ça
aurait bloqué au niveau des revendeurs
de voitures autres accusations portées
contre les garagistes des certificats de
complaisance auraient circulé pour
favoriser la revente
le ministère des transports a réagi en
supprimant l'agrément des centres un
ticket
tarif d'un contrôle minimales imposées
par la préfecture 250 francs et d'ici un
an ou deux les réparations seront
obligatoires la perspective d'une
nouvelle poule aux oeufs d'or pour les
garagistes qui voudront être à la fois
contrôleurs et réparateur pour éviter de
nouveaux abus les pouvoirs publics vont
mettre en place un nouveau système
contrôle dans l'avenir lorsqu'ils seront
assorties d'une obligation de
réparations seront effectuées par des
centres indépendants du commerce et de
la réparation automobiles donc qu'il y
aura distinction entre l'expert chargé
du contrôle et le réparateur
les garagistes français ne sont pas
seuls sur la sellette leurs voisins
européens comme est aussi quelques abus
des négociations sont en cours pour que
tous les pays du marché commun respecte
les mêmes normes
les obsèques de notre confrère de tf1
bernard giroux tué dimanche dernier aux
côtés de didier pironi ont eu lieu cet
après midi à sully-sur-loire que dire si
ce n'est que la rédaction d'antenne de
lui rend un dernier hommage à lui et à
sa famille et que vraiment il nous a
quittés beaucoup mais vraiment beaucoup
trop tôt le sport qu'il aimait tant avec
une déception aux championnats du monde
de cyclisme à vienne en autriche la
française jeannie longo vous allez
l'avoir battu en finale de la poursuite
individuelle par une américaine rebecca
twin une deuxième place donc une
médaille d'argent seulement pour jeannie
longo puisque je parle de sport devrez
vous présenter la maquette du nouveau
journal l'équipe tel qu'il va paraître
dès demain un équipe journal l'équipe
rénové avec une image une photo en
couleur tous les jours à la une
l'équipe qui devra bientôt se battre
contre un deuxième quotidien sportif en
france qui s'appellera sport voici donc
la nouvelle maquette de l'équipe en
vente à partir de demain
et puis tout de suite dès ce soir les
prévisions météo mais avant ça je
oublier le tiercé de demain
les pronostics de pierrette brès les
voici le vin le dise le 19 le 12 de 18
le neuf le 7 13 voilà je crois je n'ai
rien oublié
et cette fois ci c'est bien la boulange
voilà les prévisions météo effectivement
le temps du retour le temps du retour le
retour de vacances et le retour du
soleil aussi puisque le soleil sera là
il n'y aura pas que madonna superstar 7
ce week-end il y aura aussi le soleil
ils auront tout de suite le voir sur la
photo satellite telle qu'elle a été
prise en début d'après-midi avec vous le
voyez ici un bel anticyclone qui est sur
nos côtes donc nos côtes atlantiques
avec ce quelques nuages qui sont bien
moins la cmic sont déjà partis sont
pratiquement déjà disparition vers
l'allemagne et donc pour demain ça va
être forcé nous aurons un temps un temps
magnifique j'allais le dire en tout cas
un temps largement ensoleillé voici la
couleur de ce temps pour la journée de
demain
ce titre si elle apparaît cette couleur
du temps bon cela paraît pas c'est pas
grave il ya du soleil si la voilà la
mala du soleil partout avec quelques
brumes demain matin pour ceux qui
roulent du brouillard aussi ceux qui
vont se rentrait de vacances attention
et puis quelques nuages sur les côtes ne
pas sur les coaches haut sur les côtes
de la manche du côté de lille est
également dans l'est ce mois là pour la
couleur du temps les températures sont à
la hausse de 2 à 3 degrés par rapport à
celle d'aujourd'hui voyez ça grimpe il
faut dire aussi qu'elle vienne du diable
vauvert avec des 21 degrés le club de 21
depuis brest cherbourg lille jusqu'à
strasbourg dans l'est et puis sur la
moitié sud nous partons de 25 degrés
dans la région de clermont-ferrand
jusqu'à 30° 30 degrés en corse demain à
vienne où le soleil va à gagner ou à
perdre plutôt que quatre minutes il se
lèvera à 7h04 il va se coucher à 20h39
et bonne fête les samyn
merci laurent le dernier journal c'est
tout à l'heure en fin de programme
hervé claude qu'il ne vous le présentera
un 23h05
exactement je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end et avant cela une excellente
soirée sur antenne 2 bonsoir à lundi